the chief prosecutor of the
international criminal court is
fast-tracking an investigation into
possible war crimes in ukraine after
receiving requests from 39 countries
including canada an advanced team has
left the hague for the ukraine region
moving so fast is unprecedented for the
court to help us understand the
implications i'm joined by payam akkavan
a professor of international law at the
university of toronto and a former u.n
prosecutor professor why do you think
the head prosecutor is moving so fast
well the
invasion of ukraine
is a humanitarian disaster of
unprecedented dimensions and
while the mandate of the prosecutor of
the international criminal court is to
investigate and prosecute international
crimes
one aspect of that mandate is deterrence
basically to try and deter ongoing
violations
so while there appears to be
evidence that war crimes and possibly
crimes against humanity
are being committed
it's important also to signal to the
perpetrators that
the world is watching that their conduct
is going to be scrutinized and that
there may be a price to pay and
hopefully that will uh at least
constrain some of the worst excesses
that may be anticipated in the coming
days
there have been many reports already of
attacks on civilians in ukraine is an
intentional attack on civilians a war
crime
most certainly that is uh the uh most
emphatic war crime
but also indiscriminate attacks are
equally war crimes if you're using
weapons or methods of warfare that fail
to distinguish
between military targets and civilian
population that is also
a war crime and of course
the burden of proof is
more exacting
for establishing intentional attacks
against civilian populations but it's
enough to show that the attacks were
indiscriminate
about the burden of proof what is the
threshold for laying charges of a war
crime or a crime against humanity what
evidence will the investigators be
looking for will they be interviewing
witnesses
well yes the
witness testimony is always central to
establishing such a case
physical evidence video footage
there are multiple sources that go to
establishing a case
beyond a reasonable doubt
in the case of crimes against humanity
of course we're not dealing with
isolated or random war crimes but a
widespread or systematic attack against
the civilian population
so there has to be a significant volume
of evidence which shows that
these are in fact
massive crimes that are being committed
not just at a specific location at a
specific time
but really spread across time and a
wider geographic space
the icc is the only permanent
international court designed to address
genocide wars of aggression war crimes
and crimes against against humanity but
neither ukraine or russia are members of
the court does that matter
well unlike
let's say a canadian court international
courts only have jurisdiction where a
state has consented to that jurisdiction
the ukraine made a declaration after the
russian invasion of crimea in 2014
and it recognized the jurisdiction of
the court russia has not the basis for
jurisdiction
is that the crimes are being committed
on the territory of the ukraine so the
court has jurisdiction even if russia
has no obligation to cooperate
nonetheless the uh prosecutor uh
prosecutor's office will do what it has
to and investigate the crimes and
uh whether states are willing to
cooperate or not is an entirely
different question quick last question
since russia is not a member of the
court and we should point out neither is
the united states it has no legal duty
then to turn over its people for
prosecution so could vladimir putin if
enough evidence is found to convict him
ever face any punishment
well it's a matter of speculation uh who
would be eventually the target of an
investigation
a prosecutor will typically go where the
evidence leads
but once arrest warrants are issued
the estate that is not a party to the
statute of the court may have no
obligation to cooperate but then that
person cannot step foot outside of that
country
in particular in european countries that
are all members
of the international criminal court
because there they will face arrest and
my experience having worked as a u.n
prosecutor in respect of the former
yugoslavia is that people who are in
power today may not be in power tomorrow
and they could eventually face justice
when uh serbian president slobodan
milosevic showed up in the hague in 2001
it was a scene that would have been
unbelievable when the court was
established some years earlier so
in respect of international justice
we have to have a long-term perspective
we have to investigate uh and and issue
arrest warrants
and uh hope that the day will come
when those individuals will face justice
all right professor akavan thank you
thank you